Her low freak bitches,
you know,
when so many people are dead or driven
or,
or the,
her entire life is about fear and it's
all,
it dictates everything that they do
versus following your gut and putting
the fear aside and once you do it makes
all the difference in life.
Yeah.
Fears good.
It is a motivating factor.
Yeah.
Well it's also the lack of fear can be
very dangerous.
Absolutely.
One of the things that I always say like
people that are not scared when they're
fighting,
like those two people are in trouble.
You're in trouble,
man,
you should be fine.
Nobody likes to be scared,
but when I was competing,
the worst tournament's that I ever
fought in,
I was not nervous.
It was too confident and I just
performed poorly.
But when I was fucking terrified and
like completely on edge,
then your body's just,
it's just primal.
It's just like you get down to that,
that the bare minimum amount of
understanding of what,
what you have to do of the thinking of
the,
the rest of the world fades away and all
you're thinking about is that task.
You cutting out everything else.
There's no thought about bills.
There's no thought about the future.
There's just what's going on in front of
you right now.
And if you can get down to that,
that's when you perform at your best.
But it's fucking terrifying.
So nobody likes it.
Nobody likes to be like,
when you see guys that are in like the
UFC that are like,
like here's a good example and I'm a big
fan of Luke rockhold.
I think he's an awesome,
we were just talking about on the way
to,
he was way too relaxed.
Thought he was going to kill Michael
Bisping.
Michael bisping fought that fight.
He was going in against a fucking silver
back gorilla.
He was terrified or not terrified,
but you know,
jacked up with nerves and like you
always on the line for him.
Yeah.
That's how you walked.
Knocked him out.
Such a great sport because first knock
out too in the UFC,
it's just first Kao like that.
That's how you sell them on the way to
Jorge Rivera in Manchester and beat down
may him Miller is a Tko but the Tkos.
Yeah.
I mean he's also sitting down and its
punches better.
Jason Parillo,
his boxing coach has really been working
with him and done a fantastic job with
him and with Cris Cyborg and a bunch of
other people that the buildup to that
reminded me of Keith Jardeen talking
about Houston Alexander.
It was like,
I kept thinking like,
man,
he's really dismissive,
like cannot even in my league and all
that stuff and all of a sudden you're
done.
Yeah,
you can't.
When a guy's a professional fighter,
if you just stood there and let him
punch you in the face,
would it knock you out?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Okay.
So that it can fucking happen.
They kind of lose a bit of time.
Yeah.
And the last thing you want to be is the
guy that says,
this guy can't beat me.
I'm going to go in there and fuck them
up.
And then you wake up with a flashlight
in your eyes like,
what?
What's going on?
The Dr. Santiago,
we don't move.
You're like,
aw,
shit.
What happened motherfucker.
Yup.
And then you have to deal with that.
That ego that allow the ego tells you
that it's gonna protect you from all
this.
You know,
you're the baddest motherfucker.
You don't have to worry about shit who I
don't even have to worry.
And then you're like,
God dammit,
ego.
Ego leaves you alone.
Like,
where are you now?
Bitch gone.
It's okay to say it.
Just believe it.
Yeah.
And even if you say it,
you gotta be real fun.
Yeah.
You gotta be looking at her saying it
too.
These guys are killers.
I mean,
I just,
man,
that sports awesome.
It's a crazy sport is Brendan's got me
into it and I never missed a fight.
Now have you come live yet?
I have,
yeah.
Where have you been to live?
Went to the Thompson Hendrix.
I've been at like 25 of them.
Yeah,
he was at Thompson Hendrix know Lorenzo
Fertitta.
His nephew owns go hunt.
Yeah.
So it runs on our buddy.
So he took me,
we got full access.
Oh,
that was beautiful.
that's beautiful.
Yeah.
The big ones coming up next weekend,
you'll see to the experience alive then
on TV.
Yeah.
I was like,
wait,
I need to be able to hear Rogan so I
know what's going on.
Well,
they have these little things,
these little radios that you can get at
the,
uh,
you know,
the concession stand.
Can you really?
Yeah.
Most,
most arenas have them now.
And you take these little radios and you
turn them on and it actually has a
frequency that picks up the commentary.
Really?
Yeah.
It's excellent.
It's really cool.
I missed that part of it.
Well,
there's sometimes something's going on.
You don't know what happened.
Yeah.
And like,
like they stopped the fight.
Like,
why'd they stop the fight?
You don't realize,
oh,
it's fucking legs broken or,
yeah,
exactly.
You can,
it takes a while.
Yeah.
Commentary.
And it also,
uh,
I believe you can get,
I'm not sure about that.
There might just be fight pass.
One of the cool things about UFC fight
passes,
you could listen into the corners.
Oh,
you can.
Yes,
the corner guys are miked up.
So you can,
you can hear like someone saying,
Oh,
you know,
his hands broke,
or Oh,
you know,
uh,
this is what you gotta do that you
wouldn't,
you just get,
you get insight.
And you also get a sense of a building
up anticipation.
Like if you know that a guy's got an
injury and then he's trying to gut it
out,
it makes it even more exciting to watch.
You know?
I mean,
yeah,
it's an awesome sport.
Like I said,
I only got a couple of hobbies watching
mma,
hunting.
That's it.
And then they're,
they're very,
it's very,
they're very comparable,
like know from going from being a
wrestler.
I mean,
you,
it's just,
it's exciting.
It's slow portions of nothing in this
training and grinding and all of a
sudden,
and then every now and again you get a
step in and,
and,
and see where you're at.
I mean,
it's,
you know,
like you always say like two guys.
I mean that's,
that's a stripped down to the gets.
You either win or lose at 50 50 I'm
either going to win or I'm not.
And same with hunting.
I mean at at certain point in time and
that hunt,
you either either get them or you don't
like the percentages work out like that.
I mean that's,
that's the cool thing about it.
Well I think also like hunting,
it's very,
it's not perceived correctly by a lot of
people.
It was very misunderstood and a lot of
people think of it as this barbaric,
awful thing involving bullies and
assholes when really they're incredibly
intelligent,
difficult people were pursuing one of
the most,
one of the most difficult things to do
with dire physical consequences.
If you fail those bullies and assholes,
they don't have the dedication that get
there.
Those aren't the real guys.
Well they don't have the understanding
of who they actually are.
The T in order to face your own fears,
like a lot of the bullies and the
assholes,
like you can get a certain distance with
that,
with physical power and genetic
attributes.
Make some guys just hit fucking hard and
they're just good at taking a shot.
And if you stand in front of them,
whale with them,
they might catch you and knock you out
and beat your ass.
And you just got beat by a bully.
But the reality is when those guys get
to a steep emile chick or Cain Velasquez
or you know,
uh,
the best of the best,
they're going to get fucked up.
Yeah.
Because those guys are just as just as
physically strong,
just as kate,
but also have their mental shit in
order.
You have their ego in order.
They have their understanding in order.
And those guys are some of the nicest,
most down to earth people you ever going
to meet because they get their ego
checked on a daily basis.
Every one of them I met.
We have some guys that are customers of
ours,
um,
Tj and,
and Mendez and I mean,
they're really sharp guys.
Very Sharp and very nice,
very polite,
not assholes.
Very thoughtful.
I mean,
just great people to be around.
Okay.